foreign
this one comes from Courtney what's your
take on holding on to books pertaining
to your career for example I have a pile
of medical books that I've kept just in
case I want to reference them in the
future just in case of course are the
three most dangerous words in the
English language it's the best reason to
hold on to anything like when all else
fails just tell yourself I might need
that one day literally anything I mean
yes remember we had someone who wrote
Into the podcast you can write into US
podcasts at the minimalists.com with
your obsolete objects and one of them
was a gallstone I think from the 70s
that they were holding on to yeah just
in case what and here's the thing we
usually don't even answer the just in
case it's just I'll hold on to this just
in case well just in case what I don't
know I don't want to think about it just
in case I ever do want to think about it
as well I'm going to hold on to it yeah
and so I think that quite often happens
with books or specially textbooks that
pertain to your career
if they're useful to you meaning you've
used them here's another rule for you
that I use in my own life 90 90 right
have I used this in the last 90 days
Will I use it the next 90 I was wearing
a white T-shirt the other day and Ella
looked at me she goes you don't usually
wear that and I said Elle if I don't
wear it within 90 days I get rid of it
and so I own two white t-shirts and I
make sure that I I pepper them in
occasionally if I'm gonna wear something
under over top of it I have a white
T-shirt and it freaked her out a little
bit because she sees me in it maybe once
every three months or so yeah and then
other times I'm just wearing my
traditional black t-shirts and isn't
that what we often do though is we say I
don't have any boundary here
and so I'm going to hold on to this book
just in case of 2020 rule the 90 90
rules the seasonality rule and the truth
is if you're not using those books
regularly
still not a problem if you want to hold
on to them if you like the way they look
on your shelf yeah great but if you're
writing into a podcast and asking about
this clearly it's causing some sort of
Burden it's taking up some sort of space
that you wish it didn't take up and so
what are the boundaries that you can
make do with that give you that
permission to let go and if you're
within the boundaries by all means hold
on to it loosely but if you step outside
those boundaries
it's okay you can let it go yeah you
know I don't think that's something
we've ever really talked about the
Aesthetics of books like some books
they're beautiful and it's totally okay
to have it because it's it's art to you
um at how you have your book set up it
makes me think of The Last Bookstore
have you ever been have you been there
yet oh yeah oh man beautiful place in
that second floor how they um color
coded everything I mean it's a like an
art project on that second floor it's
downtown Los Angeles yeah if anyone
wants to make a field trip yeah it's
amazing and
um I just love how yeah like you
couldn't have that art project without
holding on to all those books it's funny
you're saying that because next week I I
know I said I was going to do during our
home tour next week I'm doing bex's she
shed that's actually two weeks from
today okay because next week I have 10
photos of all of the various books that
are the core placed throughout my home
now I have my bookshelf which are actual
books I use but then we have coffee
table books that are and also recipes
books in the kitchen and so they can be
a part of the decor as well the question
is what is the boundary that's
appropriate for you and even when I went
back to my that apartment that I hadn't
dating that we were talking about
earlier right and the big beautiful Loft
Department I found a picture just
yesterday of oh here's another photo for
you to put up on the screen here Jordan
a photo of my coffee table in that space
it was piled high with books I had no
bookshelf yeah and so intentionally
aesthetically I took all of my books
there were a couple of hundred books
maybe 100 or so books that were just
piled on top of this table and it added
an aesthetic Beauty to an otherwise
pristine space that was the boundary I
set up for myself it wouldn't be wrong
to remove all of them and get rid of
them it wouldn't be wrong to get
wall-to-wall bookshelves either the
question is what's appropriate for me in
this chapter of my life yeah
one of my favorite insights from David
Allen's getting things done is his
recommendation that whenever you start a
project you define what it means to be
done
because in the absence of such a
definition you really can't distinguish
whether you're
just fooling around with something
indefinitely Or actually aiming to
complete a project borrowing from the
same fundamental idea I would say for
anyone who is struggling with the whole
just in case business I would ask myself
what's the difference between just in
case and no matter what
what's the difference between saying I'm
holding on to this just in case I need
it
and saying I'm holding on to this no
matter what because I will always be
able to conceive a hypothetical scenario
in which its presence in my life can be
justified
right because there's always a
hypothetical scenario that could justify
you holding on to that thing so when you
say just in case I think just in case
it's just fine as long as you define
what it means to be just in case and how
that differs from no matter what and so
it's having the boundary it's like if if
I say hey Josh
let's hang out someday and Josh says
what's the difference between someday
and never at all if that statement is
Meaningful I've got to have an answer
um can we hang out before the month is
over all right I'm not committing to
next week I'm not committing to tomorrow
I haven't even committed to a specific
time but I've said Hey by the end of
this month we're going to revisit this
plan to hang out sometime and we can
make it happen so if you're going to
keep something just in case I would put
some boundaries around it and say What's
the difference between that no matter
what and like all right let's let's come
back and review this in a month or let's
come back and review this in three and
three months like what's the
hypothetical scenario you're concerned
about about when do you think that might
happen what kind of time frame all right
cool you get to hang on to it for that
long but there's got to be a reviewing
period where you come back and say all
right this is actually a no matter what
dressed up in just in case language and
I think it's time to let it go oh yeah
it makes me think how the 90 90 rule is
kind of a just in case boundary so you
look at something you're like oh I
haven't used all right I have used it in
the last 90 days and then you think
about the next 90 days and you're like
maybe but I've used it over the last
three months so I will uh let's see what
happens over the next three months so it
is like permission to hold on to
something for just in case but you have
a clear line that says this is when I'm
gonna let it go though yeah you've got a
deadline of sorts and if you keep using
it wonderful it's not a just in case
item it's a useful item but if it's
perpetually just in case that's what I'm
that's what I'm clinging that becomes a
problem did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalists
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free